Since President Trump
took office there's been
a lot of rhetoric about building a wall
along the Mexican border and imposing
a high tariff on Mexican goods.
Well, I was thinking I
wanted to take things
in a more positive direction, after all,
the beautiful thing about television
is there are no walls, no such thing.
So ladies and gentlemen, here's the plan,
I'm going to go down to Mexico City,
rent a television studio
and shoot an episode
of our show with the help
of an all Mexican staff,
crew, guests, and studio audience.
We're calling it Conan Without
Borders Made in Mexico.
(audience cheers)
I think it's gonna be fun.
No, no.
No border can contain the nonsense
that we perform on this show.
Yes.
The uselessness, the time that we waste.
Our idiocy must be shared
throughout the world.
Well, to get people in Mexico
excited about our show,
here's what we're doing,
we're posting this version
of last night's monologue
on our Team Coco website
so that everyone can get
used to my comedic stylings
south of the border, take a look.
Starbucks siempre ha sido un sitio
para gente que no tiene
no otro lugar donde estar.
(audience laughing)
Se entre, con su laptop.
Hay gente que han estado alli nueve anos
escribiendo un solo guion.
El mismo guion.
Todos estan trabajando
en el mismo guion.
(woman laughs)
(audience applauds)
I don't know why
you're a Japanese woman,
but we'll figure it out.
I'm just always touched
when someone understands
what I'm trying to do.
Again, that's Conan Without
Borders, Made in Mexico.
Our goal is to make a lot of friends.
It's airing Wednesday, March 1st at 10 pm,
right here on TBS, so watch for that.
We'll be right back.
(audience cheers)